located in the middle of the Himalayas
Nepal is one of the most isolated remote
and poorest countries in the world
additionally it has been a kind of
Protectorate a satellite country for
India however at the end of 2017 the
Communist Party of Nepal won the
elections with an overwhelming majority
and they've now set their sights on
Beijing in this video we're going to
show you what is happening and a bit
about this country's greatest hidden
treasure so let's get into it
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so I got a question for you
and please don't Google the answer that
would be cheating do you know which
country Buddha was born in 1 2 3
probably guess it's Nepal the country
located in the Himalayas which hosts
many of the highest mountains in the
world specifically in this country which
covers an area about the size of
Nicaragua we can find 8 out of the 14
summits in the entire world to reach
more than 8,000 meters and this includes
of course Mount Everest
[Music]
the country also boasts a total of 240
Peaks that reach higher than 6000 meters
in other words Nepal is a absolute
paradise for people who love mountains
and by the way Kathmandu its capital
ends the largest city in the Himalayas
is also one of Becca his favorite cities
on the planet and well why is this
well maybe it has something to do with
the fact that this city is full of
temples pagodas and alleys full of life
a capital where in the 21st century you
won't be able to find skyscrapers wide
avenues modern buses or practically any
luxury franchise it sounds pretty cool
right like one of those last drops of
history in a totally modern and global
world well as wonderful as that sounds
for a visit the reality is that Nepal is
one of the poorest countries in the
world according to the United Nations
Nepal is one of the Asian countries with
the worst human development index scores
indeed Nepal comes in at one hundred and
forty fourth in that ranking bands I be
honest this isn't really surprising
[Music]
so you despite having almost 30 million
inhabitants its economy is smaller than
that of Bolivia whose population barely
exceeds 10 million people that means
that in per capita terms Bolivia is 3
times richer than the poor that's why
with every day that passes 1,500 people
move abroad 1,500 people and if you have
this has not made it easy for the
Nepalese do you want to know why well
listen up
[Music]
a dominated country
the Paul's political system has been
anchored in the past until practically
the day before yesterday yeah in 2008
Nepal was an absolutist monarchy under
the exclusive control of the king and by
the way fun little tidbit of knowledge
right now despite being the birthplace
of Buddha and self until 2006 this was
the only country in the world where
Hinduism was the official religion but
not only that between 1996 and 2006 the
country suffered through a civil war
between governmental forces the monarchy
dictatorship forces and the Maoist
rebels who supported the establishment
of a communist Republic yes you heard
that right monarchy civil war Maoism
probably can understand now why this
country is quite so poor there has been
such a huge amount of chaos in the last
30 years that the average life
expectancy of the government was wait
for it one year but dear viewer that is
certainly not everything Nepal has
another characteristic that has greatly
conditioned its political and economic
situation see as you probably know Nepal
has no coast and have you noticed you
are their only neighbors exactly Nepal
is stuck between two giants between the
two most probable future great powers of
this century
of course that's India and that's China
two countries that moreover don't
exactly get on very well as we have seen
previously on visual politic
yes we could say that both China and
India are in the forefront of Nepal's
Ministry of Foreign Affairs mind well
the fact is that traditionally and
largely thanks to the geography the
favors at Nepal has been kind of a
satellite country for India something
the New Delhi government has always been
very very clear about India wants to
micromanage Nepal they have to control
all government appointments they have to
know everything their ambassadors behave
like viceroys aren't we a sovereign
nation Kishore Shrestha editor of jhana
Aastha national weekly and a board
member of Nepal's Press Council perhaps
the best proof of how India has always
wanted to control this remote country's
destiny happens in 2015 at that time
political forces were designing the
constitution of the newly created
Democratic Federal Republic of Nepal
well New Delhi demanded the Nepal create
a separate province for people of Indian
descent who were living in the triplane
se region in southern Nepal on the
border with India
this was something that the Nepalese
political forces emphatically
opposed they wouldn't establish
political separations based on identity
under any circumstances well when New
Delhi didn't get an affirmative answer
what do you think they did well they
blocked the borders now it was all
unofficial but provision trucks they
just stopped crossing now this would
have been bad really really bad under
any circumstances but on top of all of
that this blockade happens when the
country was at its worst it had just
suffered a huge earthquake that caused
enormous damage the deadly 7.8 magnitude
earthquake that struck Nepal in 2015 and
killed thousands of people was so
powerful it moved Mount Everest as you
know what this hasn't been the only
blockade or the only strategy that India
is used to pressure for Nepalese
politicians to follow their advice after
all trade with India has traditionally
accounted for almost three-quarters of
all Nepalese trade
but now after centuries of absolute
monarchy and decades of war and chaos
things are finally beginning to
normalize in Nepal and democracy is
gaining strength and also China's doors
that are getting too open
China's arrival
China in Nepal share a 1,400 kilometer
border and in recent years this border
has become well quite fashionable
commercial relations between both
countries have tripled since 2010 China
has also become the country that invests
the most money every year in Nepal and
tourism coming from the great Asian
power is growing rapidly
in the last 10 years alone despite the
earthquake the number of Chinese
tourists arriving in the pole every year
has multiplied by 4 at present China
Nepal relations are developing at the
fastest pace we've seen you home China's
ambassador in Nepal that's how relations
between Nepal and China are growing
hydropower to cement Chinese businesses
are already all around this small South
Asian country Chinese internet providers
are breaking Indian monopoly Chinese
tourists are flooding Nepal Chinese
language institutions are mushrooming
more Nepali students are travelling to
China than to India and hundreds of
Nepali officers are invited to China
every year as part of an unprecedented
charm offensive that's not all at the
end of 2017 elections were held to elect
a new parliament and a brand new
government
[Music]
the Communist Party's victory was
overwhelming and this is a communist
party very much influenced by Beijing
now the new Prime Minister Khar ago
Prasad Olli has boosted relations with
its northern neighbor to grow trade and
investment but also to gain independence
from India as its number one priority
and folks Beijing clearly doesn't want
to miss this opportunity
therefore Beijing is putting huge
projects on the table to change Nepal
situation
forever roads airports and above all the
promise of a new railway line because I
know a speciality of never interferes
[Music]
for example the Chinese government has
announced that it's looking into
extending the railway that connects
Tibet with the eastern coast all the way
to the Nepalese border and there is
little doubt that China would have no
problem financing the railways
construction all the way to Cat Man do
by the way we are really not talking
about a small project here connecting
Nepal and China by rail could mean
multiplying the arrival of Chinese
tourists by 10 15 or even 20 times and
if the train in addition was connected
to the Indian railway network we could
be speaking of a revolution in
transporting merchandise between the two
great Giants if we can connect this
railway network to our East West Rail
project it can revolutionize China India
trade within the Pau in the middle
Khadgar Prasad Olli prime minister of
Nepal of course the new government
doesn't intend to break ties with India
but it looks like Nepal has stopped
being New Delhi's subordinate and most
importantly for the first time it looks
like this country has a clear option for
a better future you want to know how
I'll listen up
the future water and mountains Nepal is
one of the poorest countries in the
world but it doesn't have to continue to
be so allow me to explain
on the one hand Anna Paul is a country
with nature mountains exotic landscapes
and an impressive gastronomy I mean it's
no secret that it's tourism potential is
absolutely huge
especially if communications with China
improve and as we've seen that's pretty
damn likely to happen I mean who would
not like to visit the Paul
[Music]
but that's not all in fact far from it
Nepal's great hidden treasure is
actually water
[Music]
yeah you heard that right it's really
water as we've already seen Nepal has
huge mountains and steep valleys that
have been carved by large rivers and
what can be done with all of this
natural wealth well studies conducted by
the Nepalese government show that
Nepal's abundant water resources can
produce huge amounts of hydroelectric
power at a very low cost basically its
potential power generation capacity
could be almost 50% half of all the
hydropower that is produced within the
United States and that dear viewer is a
lot of electricity now let's not forget
Nepal is located between India and China
and very close to Bangladesh these are
three fast-growing economies whose
electricity consumption is absolutely
soaring and Nepal well it may have the
capacity to supply them with the
cheapest electricity of all now of
course so far none of this has been
exploited but everything indicates that
this abandonment can be left behind very
quickly if the country regains stability
investors will line up to finance and
develop this kind of project the only
resource we have like the Arabian
countries have oil is water chubby guy
our project manager at the Russell agave
hydroelectric project a 111 megawatt
plant under construction near China's
border and the potential it doesn't end
there Nepal's new closeness to China
could make Chinese money rush into the
country in order to finance large
hydroelectric plants well that's
precisely what the Nepalese government
is thinking Nepal's new communist Prime
Minister will restart a Chinese LED 2.5
billion US dollar hydropower project
that was pulled by the previous
government considered friendly towards
India anyway the situation now is that
Nepal is still a very poor country but
with new policies it could stop being so
so will the new government be able to
leave its ideological inclinations
behind and bet on stability openness and
foreign investments well only time will
tell but now it's your turn
do you think that Nepal should bet on
China or should it continue to
strengthen ties with India well leave
your answer in the comments below as
well as in this survey and I really hope
you did enjoy this video please hit
if you did and do not forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday
also don't forget to check out our
friends at the reconsider Media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
but we're not mine and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]